what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
as a celebration of the 25th video that
I'm uploading onto this channel we are
doing a great big huge long discussion
on one of my absolute favorite villains
of all time and Marvel Comics in this
video we're going to be talking about
apocalypse so one of the funny things
about apocalypse and this is something
that I actually find pretty interesting
is that apocalypse was never supposed to
exist he was a concept that had never
really been thought of before the
original writer for x-factor Bob Layton
had been removed from the project after
the first five issues and he was
replaced by Louis Simpson
now the original intention of Bob Layton
was to have the daredevil villain owl
play the the kind of enigmatic
benefactor or mastermind behind the
alliance of evils plans to kidnap a
mutant that could boost their abilities
when Lewis Simpson came along Louis
Simpson kind of took a step away from
this and wanted to create a new villain
that had never been seen before
something that could really kind of
embody the very essence of what it meant
to be a villain in Marvel Comics
especially when you look at the basis
behind the group x-factor if you guys
remember back to our discussion on the
x-men we talked about how when the x-men
were originally founded they were not
very popular and as a result Marvel
cancelled the series and then rebooted
the series in 1975 with giant-size x-men
issue number one now for the most part
all the original founding members of the
x-men had been removed from giant-size
x-men with the exception of Cyclops but
by 1986 Cyclops had left a giant-size
x-men and he had joined the rest of the
family members of the original x-men in
a group called x-factor now at this
point apocalypse was really sort of
shadowy he really kind of had a unknown
figure an unknown
depiction in the very early days and
what we mean is that by the time issue
number six had come about apocalypse was
did was betrayed as kind of being a guy
who was covered in this weird kind of
suit we didn't exactly know what his
physical form took that took on but by
the next issue of x-factor he was
depicted in all his glory as being this
kind of big blue guy with some gray scan
and these blue lines along his face and
a giant a around his around his
waistline
now we don't know much about apocalypse
as far as the x-factor comics go suffice
it to say that he is kind of a mainstay
as a villain in the x-factor colleagues
it's not until he gets his own backstory
called the rise of apocalypse where we
learn the history behind the character
and what we learn is that apocalypse is
for all intents and purposes the very
first mutant ever now there's some
debate here there are characters that
were around before apocalypse people
like Selene for example but Selene is
what's called an external she has an
inherent mutant power that makes her
immortal but she kind of has to siphon
energy from different people she's more
or less kind of like a vampire
apocalypse has immortality but it's up
for debate as to whether or not his
immortality is a result of his merger
with celestial technology or if it was
something that he had before that took
place he lived for several thousand
years before he ever came into contact
with celestial technology but again we
don't know if that's because he has a
very lengthy lifespan or because he is
immortal at this point in time it's not
really described to us what the what the
stance is with regards to his
immortality suffice it to say in his
backstory we learned that apocalypse was
birthed I guess to a group called the
clinic have' and because of the fact
that he had such a strange physical
appearance they had viewed him as a bad
omen and they had left him to die among
the harsh environment of the Egyptian
desert much later on or shortly after I
guess the clinic have' is kind of
conquered or at least ran off by a group
called the sandstorms and this group is
led by a guy named ball and ball has
this very harsh very kind of Darwinist
viewpoint on life and this is a
viewpoint that apocalypse will carry for
the rest of his existence
all's viewpoint is that only the
strongest deserve to survive and in
around 17 years old as a rite of passage
the younger members of the tribe engage
in a kind of fight to the death among
other people in the tribe in order to
weed out the weak links and to maintain
the strength of the tribe so I guess the
best way to think about the sandstorm
errs is think about them as an ancient
Egyptian version of the Spartans so with
that being said apocalypse really kind
of solidifies himself as a strong member
of the of the sand stores and ball takes
a particular liking to him but we don't
really figure out why until much later
on as time progresses once apocalypse
reaches his 17th year is 17th birthday
so to speak he engages in a kind of
three-way fight to the death it is him
and I think it's actually three other
guys and they really are kind of out to
kill him and the reason why just because
they view him as a bad omen and had for
the longest time been attempting to
eliminate him but a rite of passage
battle to the death was really the only
way they could do it since he was really
kind of kept under the tutelage of ball
B because of the fact that the rite of
passage was an event in which ball
couldn't intervene this gave them the
perfect perfect opportunity to try to
kill him unfortunately due to the fact
that apocalypse had based mutant powers
although they hadn't quite manifested
yet he proved himself to be a formidable
enemy and actually managed to kill all
three guys now at this point what's also
taking place in the same timeline is a
pharaoh named rama tut now this is the
point in which we understand why it is
that ball had taken such a particular
and a keen interest and in apocalypse
apocalypse and Baal kind of go on this
journey this kind of journey in a cave
and Baal reveals to apocalypse several
things the first is that there was sort
of this unofficial prophecy that
dictated the coming of apocalypse not in
the sense that a priest somewhere had
made this statement but in the sense
that Rama Todd was actually not a
Pharaoh and he is not Rama Todd he's not
a divine ruler of any sort he is a
time-traveling mutant named Kang the
Conqueror and he travelled into the past
under the guise of kind of catching
apocalypse in the early days and turning
him into kind of a an individual that
could grant him abilities or someone who
could very least really kind of elevate
him to a more prominent figure because
aside from his ability to time travel
using technological devices
quema conquer has no inherent mutant
abilities as apocalypse Inbal travel
through this particular cave Bal talks
about how rabbits Hut or cane the
Conqueror had crash-landed in their time
and these Sam Stormers had nursed him
back to health
and as time progressed came to conquer
it kind of betrayed them and used
technology to his disposal to more or
less sort of conquer the Egyptian
society at the time and place himself at
the peak of authority as the Pharaoh
Baal and apocalypse also analyzed
external parts of the spaceship and Baal
reveals to apocalypse that Apocalypse
himself is depicted on different aspects
of the spaceship his futuristic facial
features his futuristic
physical form different things like that
and so ball when he first came across
apocalypse and even before he had come
across apocalypse had been on this
search for this being that had been
depicted on the spaceship of King the
Conqueror as being sort of the herald of
of the future the herald of the
beginning of a new kind of being in the
on the planet Earth so when Kang the
Conqueror learns from his Vizier I think
as Grand Vizier logos that apocalypse is
really kind of rising through the ranks
and apocalypse is alive and well in this
time period
Kane the conqueror sins Ozymandias his
general I believe along with all the
commanding forces that are needed for
this particular endeavor to destroy the
sandstorms and to capture apocalypse
alive the plan backfires to a degree the
Egyptians are ambushed by the sandstorm
errs and as a result both the Sam
swimmers and the Egyptian soldiers for
the most part all perish at this point
Ozymandias is really the only surviving
member as far as Cain the Conqueror
knows he's also aware that apocalypse is
a lot
but he doesn't realize that ball is
alive along with pocalypse eventually
ball dies in the K from several
different things from his injuries due
to the cave-in as a result of the battle
that took place outside and Apocalypse
is kind of left to to his own devices
he's kind of left by himself
apocalypse really kind of swears this
vendetta against Cain the Conqueror and
swears that you know no matter what it
takes he will inevitably destroy him
apocalypse manages to make his way into
the slave pens so to speak and becomes
kind of a slave working under the rule
of the Pharaoh where he begins again to
rise through the ranks and he eventually
catches the attention of the sister of
Ozymandias nefra now Nephi is very
important with regards to the
development of apocalypse but she
doesn't appear that often in fact she
only really appears twice when she first
meets apocalypse she is shunned she's
really kind of turned away by his
physical appearance and she perceives
him as being someone who is grotesque
and his physical appearance due to this
rejection apocalypses mutant abilities
really begin to manifest themselves in
full power so he is endowed with
enhanced strength enhanced agility the
ability to take on mass from an extra
dimensional source and again it's kind
of up for debate here immortality with
these particular abilities he really
kind of lays waste to the armies of
Ozymandias and and Cain the Conqueror
came the conqueror fleas and Ozymandias
is kind of forced into subservience for
apocalypse apocalypse later on visits
Nephi when she's much much older and
tonsure over the fact that she is aged
while he is still maintained his youth
and it's kind of this jab you know who's
who's physically attractive now you know
who looks better now kind of one of
those I guess maybe adolescent cheap
shots and that's how you guys want to
look at it in an event if you guys were
back to our discussion on the character
cable we talked about how cable goes
back into the time on several occasions
and tries to kill apocalypse well during
apocalypses life time he comes across a
being named the traveler and as we
learned in our discussion about cable
the traveler was in fact cable himself
cable attempts to destroy apocalypse and
is unsuccessful but prior to therein
agent apocalypse had come into contact
with a celestial ship but he was unable
to access access that he was unable to
make contact with it due to the fact
that his technology was far beyond
anything he was able to understand as
apocalypse and the traveler engage in
combat
apocalypse is severely wounded although
he is not killed he is however infected
with the techno-organic virus that cabl
possessed in his body at the time then
this is where things got a little hairy
we were talking about the lifecycle of
cable a cable of course had infected
apocalypse with the techno-organic virus
and due to Apocalypse being infected
with this techno-organic virus he was
able to merge with celestial technology
grant himself extra abilities which in
turn allowed him to infect cable with
the techno-organic virus several
thousand years in the future but suffice
it to say once apocalypse is able to
manipulate celestial technology he
grants himself with a multitude of
powers and this is when you really see
apocalypse move from the realm of being
a very powerful person and really kind
of the only one of its kind at the time
to being on the level of a demigod
apocalypse is now able to imbue himself
with a multitude of abilities these
include telepathy telekinesis a very
small measure of matter manipulation not
on the sense of anyone who's able to do
anything in an extreme degree his
ability to manipulate matter is really
kind of relegated to himself he's able
to alter his body on the atomic scale
and this I would say is probably his
most formidable ability because now he's
able to take on virtually any kind of
superhuman form in addition to granting
himself virtually any superhuman power
with the exception of time travel or
extreme matter manipulation from this
point forward apocalypse begins to
really kind of expand on his already
existing attempts to purge the world of
the week before apocalypse came into
contact with celestial technology he
kind of traveled the world and he would
present himself as a God so to speak to
various societies and he would pit those
societies and wars against each other in
order to eliminate the weak people of
that society
and to to maintain the existence of the
strong once apocalypse took on the
celestial technology this effort really
kind of expanded tenfold and he began to
not only pit individual I'm sorry pit
societies and conflict against each
other
but he would pit individuals against
against other people that they knew in
addition to being a conflict with
themselves for example there was a man
named Bennett Dube Harry from the 12th
century from France and this guy
eventually became the character known as
Exodus when his Leighton Union abilities
were woken up by apocalypse and Exodus
proved himself to be an extremely
formidable enemy in addition of hog lip
has also manipulated the genes of
individuals like Nathaniel Essex or mr.
sinister and probably the most notable
example Warren Worthington the third or
Archangel in addition apocalypse really
kind of boasts this this claim that he
has plans that have been in existence
for thousands of years and they are just
now unfolding to their final end for
example he had talked about an event
called the 12 which was a storyline that
played out that also involved the
scrolls a shape-shifting alien race that
on multiple occasions managed to
circumvent and I guess maybe sabotage
some of the X the the efforts of the
x-men and various various other mutants
but suffice it to say apocalypse is goal
with the twelve was to capture some of
the most prominent members of the Marvel
Universe and then channeled their
abilities into the Living Tribunal and
then in turn channel those abilities
into himself
and grant himself omnipotence as time
progresses we learned that the reason
this is done is because when he first
encountered celestial technology he also
encountered a celestial being and these
are beings that are supposedly the ones
responsible for not only the creation of
humanity but also the creation of mutant
kind and the Celestials agreed to lend
their technology to apocalypse for
future payments and apocalypse is
attempt with regards to the twelve was
to gain enough power to physically
challenged the Celestials they could
effectively not take him away or destroy
him if that was their intention the plan
ultimately backfires and apocalypse is
taken away by the Celestials
apocalypse really is he's an extremely
intelligent with regards to its
intellect because the one thing to bear
in mind is he has thousands upon
thousands of years worth of life
experience in addition to virtually all
forms of science and technology under
his belt so there really isn't anything
he doesn't know or know how to
manipulate he's also an extremely
intelligent demagogue and a demagogue as
a person who is able to rally the
beliefs or rally the desires of people
toward a single cause more often than
not people are considered to be
manipulators when they are demagogues
person like Adolf Hitler was a very
intelligent demagogue he was able to
rally an entire society towards a single
cause apocalypse will oftentimes get
involved in storylines on his own but in
terms of actually acting out a
particular event he will usually send
one of several teams one of the most
prominent or probably the most prominent
I guess group of henchmen that he has
are the four horsemen and of course with
him being fashioned with the name
apocalypse the four horsemen are taken
after the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse and so they are famine war
pestilence and death pestilence and
famine really kind of vary but no one
really cares that much about them
because some of the most prominent
members of Marvel Comics that play the
roles of war or death and so they get a
little more attention Wolverine has
played the character of death The
Incredible Hulk has played the character
of war and probably the most popular of
the horsemen death was portrayed by
Warren Worthington the third as arc
angel as time progresses we also see
groups like the writers of the dark and
the writers of the dark was a very early
incantation of the four horsemen
or I guess incarnation of the four
horsemen a very early version so to
speak but suffice it to say apocalypse
is a very intriguing character in Marvel
Comics is a very powerful character and
he pops up in some of these weird
locations he pops up in some of these
weird places for example during the
onslaught saga there were several
instances he just kind of popped up in
the middle of the onslaught storyline
watching the events unfold with who
ought to The Watcher and his argument
was that
he was not going to intervene because if
because the battle with onslaught would
reveal the week of the mutant of mutant
kind and those who were too weak to
defeat onslaught didn't deserve to exist
who watch who the watcher really kind of
came along and said well if onslaught
wins he's going to destroy everything
and that includes you in which case
apocalypse promptly changed his tune and
assisted in helping to defeat defeat
onslaught but it's very interesting when
you look at his character because he's
really kind of the amalgamation of all
the evil events that we've seen play out
we've seen a lot of characters that have
been developed and been created as a
result of his actions we've seen
characters who have this unbridled
hatred for apocalypse and their life
centers around his destruction for
example mr. sinister or cable or even
arc angel to a certain degree he really
kind of presents himself as being one of
the most formidable members of the of
the villain Airy side of Marvel Comics
and whenever the x-men engage in an
effort to defeat apocalypse is really
not an effort to destroy him one because
he can't be destroyed and two because
he's so powerful it's really kind of an
effort to hold him at bay and to it very
least at the very least circumvent
whatever planet is that he has going on
so that he really kind of has to go back
and recalculate things so with that
being said I'm going to go and bring
this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace